what most of us long for
above all else is security the sense
that we are
at last safe on the earth we pin our
hopes for security
on a shifting array of targets a happy
relationship
a house children a good profession
public respect a certain sum of money
when these are ours we fervently believe
we will
finally be at peace we may mock the term
happily ever after synonymous as it is
with
naive children's literature but in
practice
we do indeed tend to live as though we
could one day
somewhere over the horizon reach a place
of rest
satisfaction and safety it's therefore
worth trying to understand
why happiness ever after should be
congenitally
so impossible it isn't that we can't
ever have a good relationship a house or
a pension
we may well have all this and more it's
simply that these won't be able to
deliver what we hope for from them
we will still worry in the arms of a
kind and interesting partner
we will still fret in a well-appointed
kitchen
our terrors won't cease whatever income
we have
it can sound implausible especially when
such goods are still very far out of our
grasp
but we should trust this fundamental
truth in order to make an honest peace
with some rather forbidding facts about
the human condition
we can never properly be secure because
so long as we're alive
we will be alert to danger and in some
way
exposed to risk the only people with
full security
are the dead the only people who can be
truly
at peace are under the ground cemeteries
are the only definitively calm places
around there is a certain nobility
in coming to accept this fact and the
unending nature of worry in our lives
we should both recognize the intensity
of our desire
for a happy end point and at the same
time acknowledge the inbuilt reasons why
it
cannot be ours we need to give up
on what we can term the arrival fallacy
the conviction that there might be such
a thing as a destination
in the sense of a stable position beyond
which we will no longer
suffer crave and dread the feeling that
there must be such a point of arrival
begins in childhood with a longing for
certain toys
then the destination shifts perhaps to
love or career
other popular destinations include
children
family fame retirement or even
after the novel is published it isn't
that such places don't exist
it's just that they aren't places that
we can pull up at
settle in feel adequately sheltered by
and never want to leave again
none of these zones is going to afford
us with a sense that we have
properly arrived we will soon enough
discover threats and restlessness anew
one response is to imagine that we may
be craving the wrong things
that we should look elsewhere perhaps to
something more esoteric or high-minded
philosophy or beauty community or art
but that
is just as illusory it doesn't matter
what goals we have
they will never be enough life is simply
a process of replacing
one anxiety and one desire with another
no goal spares us renewed goal seeking
the only stable element in our lives is
craving
the only destination is the journey
what are the implications of fully
accepting this arrival
fallacy we can still have ambitions but
we'll have a certain ironic detachment
about what's actually likely to happen
if we fulfill them
we'll know the itch will start up again
soon enough
knowing the arrival fallacy will be
subject to illusion
but at least aware of the fact when we
watch others striving
we may experience slightly less envy it
may look
as if certain others have reached there
but we know there's still
longing and worrying up there in the
mansions of the rich
and the luxury suites of ceos
we should naturally try to give the
journey
more attention we should look out of the
window and appreciate the view
whenever we can but we should also
understand why this can only ever be a
partial solution
our longing is too powerful a force the
greatest wisdom we're capable of
is to know why true wisdom won't be
fully possible and instead pride
ourselves on having at least a slight
oversight
on our madness we can accept the
ceaselessness of certain anxieties
and rather than aim for a yogic calm
state
serenely accept that we will never be
definitively
calm our goal should not be to banish
anxiety
but to learn to manage live well around
and when we can
heartily laugh at our anxious longing
state
our calm book can educate us in the art
of remaining calm
not through slow breathing or
specialties but through thinking